1 bruno retailleau le président des
sénateurs ump est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous et avec nadège pull jacques de
l' agence france-presse notre partenaire
et perrine tarneaud bien sûr de public
sénat
alors que vous étiez avec nicolas
sarkozy un bruno retailleau il ya
quelques heures maintenant nouvelle
visite donc du président ump au sénateur
de votre groupe et vous nous raconterez
bien sûr tout à l'heure la teneur de
cette rencontre beaucoup de questions
d'actualité d'abord alors que les leçons
d'histoire sont réaffirmé avec force en
ce 70e anniversaire de la libération du
camp d'auschwitz les actes antisémites
en doublé l'an dernier des chiffres
alarmants
alors que la tuerie dans le magasin
casher au début du mois restent bien sûr
dans tous les esprits difficulté parfois
on le sait d'enseigner la shoah dans
certains établissements rejet des
valeurs de la république on a
l'impression qu'il y a le feu à l'école
et partout dans la société
absolument si la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs après les événements il ya eu
un double événement un double choc
finalement en france on est le carnage
évidemment et ensuite on s'est aperçu
que des enfants avaient refusé notamment
la minute de silence avait manifesté
notamment sur internet des actes
d'antisémitisme ou tout simplement c'est
est identifié auteurs c'est à après ce
constat que
groupe copé ump a demandé à créer une
commission d' enquête sur l'école parce
que l'école c'est le creuset de la
république
saleh fall était non de mois sombres nom
de moins en moins bien sûr pourquoi
parce que c'est finalement une
succession de renoncement et de petites
lâchetés depuis des dizaines d'années
quand monsieur bourdieu nous expliquer
que l'autorité du professeur c'était
nécessairement l'oppression des élèves
quand on nous expliquait que à la suite
de 68
l'autorité est une forme de maltraitance
des élèves quand jusqu'à aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs quand ont commencé à remettre
en cause les notes et qu'il fallait et
transformé par des couleurs parce que
finalement on pouvait là encore molesté
deux têtes brunes blondes apparemment
françois hollande à renoncer à cette
idée là ça vienne il a review sait très
bien à l'actuelle a jamais alors c'est
tombé chose et peut-être aussi les
amener où la droite était au
gouvernement je dégage au désir des
pauvres yeux des rapports sur les cols
du sang de 1400 jeu bien ce qu'ils n'ont
pas été suivis je fais je pense à celui
notamment de jean pierre aubin qui est
inspecteur général de l'éducation
nationale il l'était à l'époque et il a
dénoncé un certain nombre de choses il
ya eu d'autres rapports depuis
mais aujourd'hui il faut que l'école
transmette un certain de savoir il faut
qu'elle revienne aux fondamentaux ses
fondamentaux c'est des apprentissages
parce que on peut pas se contenter quand
il ya pratiquement 20% des élèves qui
rentrent au collège qui maîtrisent mal
les savoirs fondamentaux l'écriture la
lecture ou le calcul c'est une
catastrophe
ensuite l'école notamment l'école
républicaine et impact en france entre
la république et puis son école c'est
une transmission de valeurs des valeurs
qui sont une grammaire commune pour
qu'une société puisse vivre ensemble il
y a donc cette commission enquête mais
la ministre de l'éducation nationale a
déjà réagi ainsi que le premier ministre
ni un plan pour l'école pour justement
remettre dans la tête des élèves les
valeurs de la république
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin on
entend certains à gauche comme à droite
d'ailleurs prenez par exemple le retour
d'un service national républicain pour
tous les garçons et toutes les filles
oui non mais vous êtes favorable moi je
suis plutôt favorable sur toute chose
alors qu' on puisse avoir un creuset
pour qu'on puisse avoir cette apprentie
ses toiles ne suffit pas il faut aussi
en médias les familles
les familles et moi ce qui me je pense
qu'on peut aussi envisager pour des
familles qui dans les enfants à
répétition ne manquent l'école où
manifestent un tempérament pas seulement
ombrageux il est manifeste que ils sont
en rupture avec les valeurs
fondamentales de la république vient
joie de sanctions financières je pense
oui bien sûr les allocations familiales
il faut en même temps responsabiliser
les familles alors on ne fait pas d'un
coup on peut auditionner les familles
mais il faut en même temps dire aux
familles vous avez un devoir de
responsabilité et d'autorité et on ne
peut pas tout décharger tous demandé à
l'école la défaillance des familles
l'école ne peut pas tout rattrapé il
faut que l'école assume sa
responsabilité les valeurs républicaines
mais en même temps les familles doivent
aussi assumer l'autorité parentale or il
ya de nouvelles voies par exemple xavier
bertrand à l'ump qui demande le
déploiement de l'armée dans les
quartiers en société socialiste samia
ghali avait la première émis cette
hypothèse est ce que vous êtes favorable
non moi je pense que l'armée en france
selon lui demande beaucoup de choses la
relève elle doit écouter je pense moi
que ce terrorisme là ce nouveau
terrorisme qui est nouveau à la fois par
sa nature et sa dimension par sa nature
parce qu'il s'écoulait dans les habits
de la mondialisation il connaît pas de
frontières ils utilisent internet et et
en même temps par sa dimension parce que
c'est un phénomène qui est en train de
prendre une ampleur inhabituelle y
compris chez nous en france
moi je pense que le premier des fronts
c'est non seulement le front intérieur
le front extérieur demandant à l'armée
de se consacrer sait ce qu'elle fait au
front extérieur que ce soit en irak que
ce soit au mali etc alors à lunel
justement vous parlez de ce terrorisme
intérieur qui se répand avec
l'interpellation de cinq personnes
proches de djihadistes dans cette petite
ville un de l'hérault il ya vingt-six
mille habitants on sait qu'il ya déjà
vingt jeunes qui sont partis pour le
djihad en syrie on a l'impression que
c'est une spirale infernale
bien sûr il ya une grotesque venant
racines mans ya à la fois une
augmentation exponentielle et un
enracinement
alors lorsque le président de la
république alors lorsque le président de
république nous a reçus à l'elysée il
nous indiquait un chiffre de 1280
français
30 % étaient des femmes 20% des mineurs
ça pose question et on adoucit les
convertis donc ils sont ces gens là sont
français ils ont grandi sur le sol
français et ils ont été à l'école de la
république
donc on a un vrai problème moi je pense
que il bien des points qui sont qui
concerne le pénal la sécurité
l'isolément des prisons dans les prisons
et ne non c'est pas le premier mais
évidemment les prisons doivent être un
bouclier elle s'était transformé en
glaive contre la société
je pense que il faut élargir les
conditions de rétention de sûreté que
l'on dit je pense qu'il peut y avoir un
certain nombre d'infractions et qu'on
doit expulser les notamment les
étrangers qui sont sur le sol français
et qui font l'apologie du terrorisme et
dans une mare mais les prix nationaux
qui rentrent du jazz et bien le conseil
constitutionnel vient vous savez il ya
quelques jours simplement mais avec
forte nous rappeler qu' on peut démettre
de la nationalité française des
binationaux voilà et bien il faut
prendre ces mesures
il ya d'autres mesures alors on a parlé
de l'école l'organisation dit sam en
france c'est une évidence
je crois que sur les 1500 imam il y en a
à peu près 50% qu'il ne parle pas le
correctement le français
on doit avoir mon pas l'islam en france
l'islam de france il ya même un 15 % qui
sont à pointer par l'état turc
ça ne peut pas coller il ya un travail
je le dis tout en réaffirmant qu'il ne
s'agit pas de faire des amalgames
mais en même temps je pense que la
communauté musulmane de france pour
s'intégrer à la république est justement
refusé le communautarisme doit faire un
travail d'organisation sur elle même et
au sein de la république
alors vous parlez du front extérieur
également il a nous avons en ce moment
deux ennemis en syrie il y à bachar
el-assad et puis également le groupe
armé islamique faut-il donner la
priorité à l'un sur l'autre puisqu'on
entend désormais des voix par exemple en
abuse dire que certes il faut abattre il
faut que le dictateur par mais il faut
en même temps sauvegarder
un état dans la syrie écoutez moi je
pense je me suis rendu à deux reprises
sur place j'ai constaté j'avais été le
premier parlementaire l'époque où mois
d'août
et quand j'avais reçu en direct les
témoignages des minorités notamment
chrétiennes et yézidie qui m'avait parlé
de crucifixion d'éventration de femmes
enceintes de décapitation toute chose
qu'on allait apprendre ensuite notamment
avec vos confrères les journalistes qui
ont été massacrées notamment égorgé
donc on a en face de nous une barbarie
un islamo fascisme
un totalitarisme voilà qui serait la
priorité c'est pour moi la priorité est
la priorité et cette priorité là on doit
éradiquer
l'état islamique dahesh on doit les
rééduquer aussi bien en irak qu'on doit
l'éradiquer en syrie et on ne peut pas
puisque il se fiche des frontières ils
ont fait un état transfrontaliers et je
pense que monsieur bachar el-assad
les uns en fait je pense que laisse
tranquille c'est pas cela mais notre
priorité c'est la lutte contre eux des
ch
dans un premier temps maintenant
monsieur bachar al assad n'a pas
vocation à rester
je veux dire à la tête de ce régime mais
je crois que rien ne serait pire les
américains nous en ont fait une funeste
démonstration en irak quand on contribue
à détruire un état
derrière l'état ya le chaos et avec le
chaos
on le voit aussi en libye on a
finalement des mouvements violents on à
la barbarie qui s'installe sur la ruine
des états faillis alors vous avez parlé
de la turquie justement il a fermé sa
frontière après et bien la perte de la
bataille de coban et par le groupe etat
islamique 1 au profit des des kurdes il
ya même eu des des violences d'ailleurs
du côté de la frontière votre jugement
sur le rôle de la turquie qui
apparemment donc les plus facilement
passer les jihadistes français qui
partent pour la syrie que les kurdes et
qui veulent rejoindre leurs frères de
sang la turquie est un état qui
appartient le temps qui appartient à la
grande coalition qui est censée lutter
contre l'état islamique c'est un grand
peuple
mais j'étais de ceux j'avais posé une
question au gouvernement il ya quelques
semaines justement au moment de la
bataille du début de la bataille de
coban et quand les turcs retenait
finalement les pechmergas les kurdes et
qu il s est passé parfois
et souvent même les jadistes et je crois
qu'il faut lever l'ambiguïté quant on
voit que la turquie refuse aux avions de
la coalition de s'envoler à partir et de
décoller à partir lever l'ambiguïté made
est clair c'est à dire qu' il faut que
l'ennemi déclaré soit non pas les cures
que ce soit les taxes night ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire ouvrir les frontières
pour renforcer les kurdes ceux qui
luttent contre l' état islamique ça veut
dire ouvrir à la grande coalition ses
bases aériennes
on serait beaucoup plus efficace si nous
avions les avions de la coalition
décoller et atterrir à partir des basses
turc alors de lever les ambiguïtés
dites-vous un bruno retailleau il ya il
faut qu'on parle du qatar donc aussi les
critiques et autres enfin tous les cas
la relation entre la france et le qatar
est critiquée par certains par exemple à
l'ump bruno le maire on sait qu'il ya
une bienveillance du qatar également de
l'arabie saoudite pour
les frères musulmans et ce qu'il faut
dans ce contexte là imaginer comme
certains de vos amis groupe ump créé un
groupe d'amitié france qatar au sénat
aujourd'hui il existe des groupes
d'amitié et il n'y a pas de groupes
d'amitiés qatar il est inclus dans un
groupe d'amis il faudra de toute façon
il faudra de toute façon continuer à
parler entre les états c'est important
pour nos diplomaties mais il faut dire
aussi bien l'arabie saoudite que aux
pays du golfe que on a un ennemi qui est
commun et la sueur cela il faut un
groupe d'amitié spécifique avec le kata
ou pas ou l'autre aviez-vous moi je
pense que non vous pensez que non moi je
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a voilà
si elle un sous-groupe et le sous-groupe
convient très bien il n'y a pas de
l'imsak très bien on va parler de 2,2 du
climat d'union nationale et qui s'est
développé dans ce pays certains disent
que c'est déjà du passé on va en parler
dans un instant avec nadège pull jacques
est ce que vous pensez que la poussette
popularité de françois hollande et
durable alors qu'on vient de découvrir
les chiffres du chômage une nouvelle
hausse au mois de décembre +0 2% et sur
l'ensemble de 2014 une progression de
5,7 pour cent
écoutez comme vous et d'autres sans
doute on a marché le 11e en janvier
dernier mois pour la première fois j'ai
constaté que les français étaient une
communauté nationale que la république
était de rester debout on a marché
contre le terrorisme et pour la
république pour nos valeurs et c'est
quelque chose d'important je pense que
le président de la république qui a été
à la hauteur comme le premier ministre
et je pense que c'est important de le
dire maintenant ça devrait vous n'avez
plus contesté le fait qu'ils veulent est
en capacité d'occuper la fonction comme
on l'a beaucoup entendu dans
l'opposition il ya un certain nombre de
doutes qu'ils ont levé malheureusement
les doutes sur le plan économique ne le
sont pas et non je pense que je pense
que la politique économique de françois
hollande et est assez catastrophique on
va bien voir avec les chiffres du
chômage mais il faut se rappeler que le
déficit de 2014 et supérieur difficile
de 2013
il faut savoir aussi que depuis qu'il
est élu il ya plus d'un million
demi million de chômeurs en france que
l'année 80 2014 a été l'année record
pour les faillites d'entreprises
donc je crois que les moyens qu'ils
utilisent
sa politique est en train d'échouer sur
son plan là or on sait qu'il ya quand
même correspondance entre cette
dégradation du climat social économique
et des vocations éventuel pour le
mondial
vous nous direz dans un instant si vous
êtes très vous a voté la loi macron
puisque il ya certains parlementaires de
l'ump qui s'apprêtent à le faire on va
donc parler de la situation à l'ump de
ces propositions de ces difficultés
aussi peut-être à se différencier dans
ce climat d'union nationale même si
nicolas sarkozy en parle désormais au
passé
avant d'accueillir la dèche peljak de la
sp donc le reportage
aujourd'hui deux gérants dragué
justement sur les traces du président de
l'ump
dur dur d'être chef de l'opposition et
de se faire entendre en pleine période
d'unité nationale
d'autant plus quand on s'appelle nicolas
sarkozy avec un caractère plus connus
pour l'affrontement que pour
l'apaisement alors à la première
occasion quand manuel valls évoque une
situation d'apartheid en france le
président de l'ump reprend les
hostilités je suis consterné par cette
expression et par le fait que le premier
ministre de la république française on
prend une expression de cette nature
réplique immédiate du premier ministre
qui en appelle à l'esprit du 11 janvier
tout le monde est à commencer par les
responsables politiques
et bien sûr ceux qui gouvernent comme
ceux qui hier ont gouverné doivent est
grand à petit
trois semaines après les attentats
nicolas sarkozy veut pourtant tourner la
page
et d'abord rassembler son camp en
choyant notamment les anciens premiers
ministres et probables futurs
concurrents
une séance de calinothérapie prolonger
ce matin la réunion du groupe ump du
sénat où il est venu dans un esprit de
concorde sans s'imposer encouragé le
groupe ump du sénat a proposé
à imaginer les conditions de
l'alternance et pu faire jouer au groupe
ump du sénat un rôle essentiel dans la
prochaine compétition électorale qui
sera celle de la direction de tous nos
départements
objectif départementale pour prolonger
le succès des municipales et pas
question de se taire face à l'exécutif
at il confié au sénateur va pas rester
en permanence quelles que soient les
tentations de l'exécutif de nous
enfermer dans ce piège selon lequel il
faudrait être d'accord sur tout sur la
réforme régionale sur la métropole sur
lui pourquoi pas sur les cantonales
aussi on pourrait peut-être union
familiale à l'ump plutôt qu'une union
nationale avec l'idée d'écouter tout le
monde alors le nicolas sarkozy nouveau
est il arrivé est comme le bon vin se
bonifie t-il avec le temps c'est en tout
cas ce qu'il a confié aux parlementaires
à la veille de ses 60 ans avec l'âge il
était de plus en plus disposés à écouter
les conseils des uns et des autres est
de plus en plus disposés à ne plus
décider seul voilà donc déjà sur le tour
de boutade mais je sais pas si on l'a
tous cru reste à prouver désormais qu'il
pourra unir sa famille politique dans la
durée pour l'emmener vers de nouveaux
succès montée sur l'alternance de
l'unité nationale vient de vivre une
période assez difficile pour elle et ça
lui qu'il a fallu qu'elle respecte la
trêve on peut parler de trêve je crois
d'unité nationale mais en même temps
elle a fallu qu'elle fasse entendre sa
différence comme partis de l'opposition
comment est ce que vous avez vécu cette
période ben je l' ai vécu comme beaucoup
de français il ya quand même eu d'abord
le choc la sidération il ya eu cette
fierté un peu d'être français on l'a vu
en janvier lors franchement c'est aussi
là pour moi c'était très très fort pour
moi c'est tv c'était beaucoup d'émotions
vraiment et puis ensuite il ya la tente
des français qui exige de nous qu'on
tire les leçons pourquoi c'était
possible et comment peut-on faire pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
donc finalement moi je pense que les uns
et les autres ont été à leur place
car nicolas sarkozy
parle on dit qu'il en fait trop quand il
se tait qu'il participe à l'union est
rude et qu'il en fait pas c'est que
c'est compliqué pour lui
non je pense que aussi bien d'ailleurs
l'exécutif que l'opposition dont je
pense qu'on a fait preuve en était à la
hauteur des événements
je pense à tout le monde a tenu son rang
je les mets d'ailleurs c'est pas nous
qui le disons que l'assemblée nationale
maintenant on va le voir avec la loi
macro ont d'ailleurs se le manger de loi
est en discussion à l'assemblée nicolas
sarkozy donc le président de l'ump a
demandé à tous les parlementaires ump de
voter contre mais il y en a qui n'ont
ils ont passé outre et qui sont pas
d'accord et je pense à frédéric lefebvre
thierry mariani j'ai noté leur nom là
olivier carré hervé mariton est tous des
députés je ne sais pas peut-être qu'il
ya aussi chez les sénateurs
comment est ce que vous considérez cela
est ce que ces personnalités de l'ump
ces élus de l'ump portent atteinte à la
cohésion de votre parti en respectant
pas le mot d'ordre de nicolas sarkozy
est-ce qu'ils sont dans leur rôle début
de la république et puis après bien sûr
vous nous donnez s'il vous même
écoutez vous même vous avez là je viens
de conviction et je suis trop attaché à
la liberté pour la dernier chez d'autres
et je trouve que quand on est
parlementaire il faut prendre ses
propres responsabilités
donc vous savez beaucoup senaya pas
d'embrigadement ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que vous conseiller d'aller
au parti gana l'union non plus non plus
je vous assure
l'union nationale évidemment l'union
nationale ça ne veut pas dire non plus
le silence l'uniformité nationale il
faut pas que l'exécutif tire cette
ficelle pour museler l'hôpital il s'agit
plus de la loi macron et pour la loi
macron moi je vais vous dire ce que l'on
va faire et on va le faire avec
avec le centre on a on va avoir une
commission spéciale qui va être
d'ailleurs présidée par quelqu'un qui
est très très très performant qui
s'appelle vincent capo-canellas ce qui
est de lutter avec des rapporteurs qui
seront ump eh bien on va dire à monsieur
macron il faut tirer les leçons de tout
ce qui arrive est une des leçons c'est
de nommer les choses camus disait vous
savez mal nommé
les chaussées à vis de robert dumont
exactement et bien le sur le plan
économique c'est l'échec c'est un échec
total
et ça n'est pas je suis désolé avec la
loi macron qu'on va faire quoi que ce
soit sur le chômage
donc ce que nous allons faire nos sénat
on va dire monsieur macron savez dans
les premières semaines quand vous étiez
encore un peu ingénu tout fraîchement
arrivé vous avez déclaré que les seuil
c'était terrible pour les entreprises
que les 35 heures c'était aussi le
problème qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de freins alors on va dire à monsieur
macron écoutez vous en avez rêvé
eh bien nous au sénat on va le voter on
va faire du super super macro vous le
prenez au pied tablette mais quand il
n'était pas encore ministre quelques sic
quand il est devenu certains articles
dans nova on va amender la loi et on va
dans la loi il mettre des dispositifs
qui priorise absolument c'est à dire que
assemblée il ya un jeu de rôle qui est
inverse nous on va le renverser et on va
dire voilà ce que l'on croit voilà ce
que les chefs d'entreprise et les
salariés aussi faux pas distinguer les
deux pensent que attendent de nous pour
essayer de faire en sorte créé à nouveau
demain dans cette loi tout n'est pas
mauvais quand même mais c'est la seconde
pour que ça plaise à l'ump à savoir dans
la mer mais ya pas d il ya 200 personnes
il ya 200 articles réforme et vous
apprécierez d'accord on est tout à fait
d'accord et c'est bien c'est d'ailleurs
le reproche que j'adresse à ma propre
famille politique en pensez bien que si
je l'adresse à ma propre famille
politique
j'attends un même temps de l'opposition
actuelle qui dans maintenant devenu
majorité est bien calé en même temps
tirage de réformes ayant ne comprennent
pas que vous reposiez un texte qui va
dans votre sens qui est dans quel sens
va t'il sinfra
mais non mais bon non il prône un
programme socialiste
c'est un projet de communication comme
fait habitudes comme on fait d'habitude
avec françois hollande
on proclame l'économie de l'offre est en
réalité il y a des mots sont les actes
et monsieur macron être d'une habilité
tout commander rien énarchique en tout
cas très tracé assez fine mais je veux
dire que ça n'est pas avec la loi dite
macron
on relèvera l'économie française c'est
une certitude absolue
quid des 35 heures quid du du code de
travail qui a des plus compliquées quid
des effets de seuil pourquoi est-ce
qu'en france on a deux fois plus
d'entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
que de plus de 5 ans parce que quand
vous ajoutez quand vous reprend bauchet
une ou deux personnes de plus vous avez
35 contraintes administratives qui vous
tombe sur le dos qu'est ce que fait
monsieur macron pour les entreprises et
notamment les petites les pme sur ce
plan là à rien donc j'en ai gr
reviennent avec l'ailé à être à la
hauteur
le grand premier ce que vous dites
n'empêche qu'il ya quand même des
députés chez vous qui vont la voter
cette loi est ma question c'est le
chercher ce qui est atteinte à la
cohésion de votre parti ou bien ce
qu'ils sont dans le rôle de la
république ce à quoi mme vous énervez
qu'il voit de ce que les gens mais je
vous ai répondu je n'ai pas moi je suis
écouté je préside le groupe des center
je vois la caserne députés pour moi
c'est pas bien sûr que c'est pas
l'embrigadement et ça n'est pas non plus
l'encasernement c'est une évidence c'est
comme ça d'ailleurs que je tente au
quotidien d'animer le groupe des
sénateurs qui sont très attachés à la
liberté liberté de parole liberté de
vote et elle encore attachés à la
liberté parle et parle de parole est ce
que vous êtes toujours sioniste
écoutez moi j'ai un lien d'affection
avec françois fillon qui est en même
temps un lien de conviction je pense que
les propositions que françois fait
notamment sur l'économie
je pense qu'il a compris par exemple que
c'est vrai sont à cadix
très franchement les plus poussées et la
droite il fout il travaille et je pense
que la france s'en tirera qu'avec des
propositions qui sont fortes
est-ce qu'on voit bien que les
demi-mesures ça ne fonctionne plus
est-ce que c'est lui qui est le meilleur
pour représenter votre camp allez y aura
des primaires à des primes nous vous le
soutiendrez la primaire
et bien écoutez moi je suis proche de
lui bien sûr mais ce que je veux dire ce
que je veux c'est des primaires qui
soient des primaires ouvertes
nicolas sarkozy s'est engagé et j'espère
que le meilleur gagnera il nous faudrait
entre 2 millions et demi 3 millions au
moins de 2 kg de votants c'est à dire
des sympathisants de droite pas
seulement de l'ump mais du centre et
d'au-delà tous ceux qui se reconnaissent
de notre philosophie politique pour
on puisse déterminer le meilleur on peut
franchement on peut pas continuer je
veux dire avec la politique telle que le
on a aujourd'hui avec françois hollande
ça n'est pas possible
et si par hasard ce n'était pas lui
monsieur fillon qui était désigné la
primaire votre préférence et qui nicolas
sarkozy c'est écouter ce que je constate
en soi mais c'est xavier bertrand au
ghana du monde c'est évident à l'âge
auquel je vous essayez de me faire
endroits non non mais je perds en
presque ce que je peux vous dire en tout
cas c'est que je sais gré actuellement à
nicolas sarkozy de rassembler la famille
vous le disiez tout à l'heure la famille
absolument absolument exact on entendait
des sénateurs on avait l'impression
qu'ils nous disaient que le président de
votre formation forcer un peu son jeu
nous avons activé alors voilà alors
écoutez jean chez vous qui le vivent
devant la caméra non écoutez moi je
trouve que sont sa première
responsabilité
on parlait et quelques instants de
l'union nationale est ce que vous
imaginez un seul instant la réaction de
nos militants
la réaction des français si on
entretenait et on nourrissait une guerre
des chefs à l'ump ce serait absolument
désastreux ce serait la fin de l'ump et
ce serait évidemment de l'eau au moulin
de tous les extrémismes donc je pense
que le travail qu'il fait est important
il est nécessaire c'est difficile pour
lui peut-être for style de sa nature
l'importance que je constate moi je les
constate et encore ce matin c'est que il
ya une volonté de rassembler et sans
rassemblement au brassage n'aura pas les
français sur les pas capables de se
rassembler de vous parler des électeurs
est ce que vous craignez pour la france
une volatilité des électeurs comme on
l'a constaté en grèce par exemple ou
parti socialiste s'est effondré où il ya
un mouvement d'extrême gauche qui a
émergé
bien sûr mais quel est le risque est la
leçon grève la leçon grec c'est que
quand on laisse les choses aller trop
loin quand on fait pas les vraies
réformes les réformes on les subit et ça
profite finalement aux extrêmes de
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche
c'est ça la leçon de la grèce que je lis
très peu
sous la plume de certains d'un certain
nombre d'observateurs
mais si on ne fait pas des réformes
consenti expliquer rapidement un jour la
france peut se trouver dans une
situation difficile
si jamais les taux d'intérêt augmentent
et parce que vous avez la france ne
rembourse pas aujourd'hui capital de sa
dette on paye les intérêts et non pas
une service de la dette
bien sûr mais chaque jour qui passe
notre dette augmente et et je pense que
il ya alors que on a un euro qui est
faible alors qu'on a des taux d'intérêt
qui sont faibles des matières premières
etc
je pense qu'il faut profiter de ce
moment là la banque centrale assouplisse
sa politique monétaire profitons-en
justement pour faire des réformes qu'ils
soient pas les réformes être de monsieur
maquereau ou de france ou alors je
voudrais bien revenir quand même à la
haye ump le 7 et le 10 février
alors elle non mais c'est très active et
vous pourrez poser la question j'y tiens
alors l'ump tient son conseil national
les 7 et 8 février
au programme y aura les élections
départementales est d'abord comment
s'annonce ces élections pour vous alors
je veux dire elles se sont jamais aussi
mal ah non c'est pas pour moi mais pour
ceux qui ont honte à être candidat parce
que on vient de découper monsieur valls
a fait un découpage de la france comme
j'aime en a connues depuis 200 ans les
cantons de tous les cantons
ensuite on a un mode de scrutin que le
monde entier observe comme une curiosité
très exotique avec les minots partie
vous allez gagner ces débordements
oui c'est une chose et enfin et enfin
nos candidats ne vont même pas savoir et
ne savent pas actuellement quelles
seront les compétences des départements
en bref les attributions l'émission des
départements puisque on y entendra d'en
discuter l'assemblée va en discuter dans
quelques semaines c'est incroyable si on
voulait faire monter la tension ou
monter les extrêmes on ne s'y prendrait
pas d'une autre façon alors qui est des
pros next des pronostics favorables pour
ma famille bien sûr mais permettez moi
de temps en temps de ne pas raisonner
uniquement en des termes partisans ou
militants
mais de voir en même temps l'intérêt
général de la france est ce que je
constate si jamais une élection qui sera
nationale puisqu'on va renouveler
l'ensemble
des cantons danse et départementales
jamais une élection ne s'est déroulée
dans un tel flou jamais je voulais la
sueur sous la vème république
en tous les cas en cas de second tour
entre ap et intra candidat ps avait
fourni des faits nous appeler à voter
pour qui entre un candidat fn et après
on est sur la doctrine du ni ni
voilà sur le nier voilà alors donc voir
ça les besoins ou dites à vos électeurs
d'aller à la pêche et écouter pour nous
pour nous les choses sont claires c'est
une doctrine qu'on a défini pour notre
famille politique et les choses sont
assez assez clair alors on parle de la
rsm et biars à bientôt une nouvelle ump
a c'est le désir de monsieur sarkozy qui
veut refonder votre parti il y aura un
congrès fondateur avant l'été on avait
parlé d'avril mais finalement ce sera
avant l'été et on va même changer le nom
du parti est ce que ça vous convient à
tout cela je suis pas ump je suis pas un
grand fanatique de tout ça ce qui est
important pour moi c'est le projet
d'ailleurs et et et le groupe au sénat
on va faire un séminaire la semaine
prochaine le groupe va y contribuer
puisque on va définir une dizaine de
thématiques et notre ambition au sénat
c'est de préparer l'alternance de 2017
c'est d'avoir un certain nombre de
propositions fortes pour réformer la
france en profondeur sur tous les
aspects des aspects bien sûr les caddies
un programme pour l'ump puis après la
primaire un arbre chaque candidat dans
un contribuer
on va contribuer écoutez je pense qu'une
des grandes forces du sénat c'est la
réflexion c'est la profondeur on est
souvent détachés de l'actualité et on
peut prendre de la hauteur et moi je
vais utiliser cette force de réflexion
pour contribuer prévu précisément pardon
à la préparation de l'alternance de 2017
voilà merci nadège perrine tarneaud de
public sénat arrive maintenant alors que
le sénat a voté ce mardi justement une
nouvelle répartition des pouvoirs sur le
territoire vous en parliez à l'instant
monsieur retailleau adoption par 192
voix pour 11 contre avec l'abstention de
la gauche il faut le dire des
compétences donc entre les territoires
les régions renforcée mais les
départements voisins président et un
sont loin d'être affaiblie ils sont
toujours là d'ailleurs
présentation de cette nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république comme l'ont dit avec marie
brémond
on attendait un grand chambardement
c'est finalement une réforme timide la
loi notre nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république devait
redistribuer les compétences
qu'en est il concernant les régions le
gouvernement et les sénateurs disent oui
à des compétences élargies développement
économique innovation ou encore
coordination des acteurs de l'emploi et
de la formation professionnelle mais pas
question de leur laisser les collèges ni
les transports scolaires où la voirie
départementale
il reste aux départements certains y
compris dans la majorité au sénat
dénonce une occasion ratée mais je pense
qu'ils ont tort de s'arc-bouter surtout
parce que ça ça donne une image au fond
qui n'est pas positive et qu'il n'est
pas suffisamment qui montre pas
suffisamment qu'ils ont besoin de la
réforme les départements garde donc
collège transports scolaires voirie et
se voient confortés dans leur rôle de
garant des solidarités sociales et
territoriales
ce texte est d'une certaine manière
quand même mise en échec de la volonté
initiale du gouvernement qui voulait
à l'origine profite de ce texte pour
dévitalisées les départements et à terme
aux fins de les faire disparaître
pas de disparition des départements mais
pas touche non plus aux
intercommunalités
le gouvernement voulait augmenter le
seuil minimal des intercommunalités à
20000 habitants hors de question pour
les sénateurs de la majorité
le seuil restera à 5000 habitants
au grand dam du gouvernement et de
l'opposition au sénat qui à demi-mot
dénonce les prés carrés de certains
barons locaux ya beaucoup de présidents
de conseils généraux qui viennent
défendre leurs convictions où il se
trouve que souvent leurs convictions
c'est de défendre un peu bâclé ou le
département donc là c'est certain que
c'est difficile de faire évoluer les
départements lorsqu'on a beaucoup de
défenseurs acharnés le département mais
le débat n'est pas terminé c'est au tour
de l'assemblée nationale d'examiner ce
texte avant qu'il ne revienne au sénat
délicate question du redécoupage du
territoire et surtout des nouvelles
compétences attribuées aux roses aux
pieds des procès la confiance des
corporatismes il va falloir répondre à
tous affiché un badge pas touche à mon
millefeuille
pas touche à mon département non non non
ça n'est pas du tout ce qu'on a fait
d'ailleurs la gauche s'est abstenue
on a essayé de remettre un peu d'ordre
dans le désert du gouvernement quatre
changements de pied comme un casse tête
à queue sur le département françois
hollande qui decker en corrèze c'était
il ya tout juste un an que des plantes
le département est irremplaçable
quatre mois après on le supprime et
ensuite on dit bon on aime tellement peu
le département convent croix et créé
trois sortent ensuite on maintient le
département non qu'on est d'accord qu'il
ait beaucoup d'atermoiements de la part
du gouverneur
est ce que c'est une bonne raison quand
même pour ne toucher à rien ou on a trop
difficilement c'est bouger les lignes
assez faux c'est faux on essaie d'avoir
justement une cohérence une ligne au
sénat proximité décentralisation et est
en plus modernité
la décentralisation le gouvernement
voulait redistribuer les cartes entre
les régions les départements et l'a fait
en fait nous ce que nous souhaitions en
même temps c'est renforcer les régions
sur la politique de l'emploi
on était d'accord pour de grandes
régions mais on s'est dit ok d'accord le
gouvernement vous a un peu forcé la main
non l'accompagnait puisqu'on a voté le
premier texte et on a dit au
gouvernement très bien que les régions
et les manettes du développement
économique mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire d'avoir les manettes de
développement économique si on n'a pas
un peu de manettes de l'emploi qu'est ce
que veut dire le développement
économique s'ils ne contribue pas à la
lutte contre le chômage l'unedic et nous
on a voulu non no no no no no no 1 au
niveau non pas dans le gouvernement
voulait que l'état reste avec les
manettes de l'emploi nous on est
décentralisateur on a de l'audace
ensuite quand vous avez des très grandes
régions très très grande région qui font
l'équivalent par équipement pour
certaines de la belgique
comment voulez-vous supprimer les
départements est ce que c'est de
bordeaux qu'on va comment dirais je
commandais le salage l'hiver des routes
départementales du limousin sur la route
de la souterraine de guéret c'est une
vue de l'esprit technocratique à partir
du moment où vous avez de grandes
régions il ya besoin de la proximité
parce que sinon les élus ils sont très
très très loin des territoires et à ce
moment là encore une fois les citoyens
constatent une forme d' éloignement
qu'il repousse d'accord donc ça c'est
votre vision des choses ici au sénat
bruno retailleau
quel est votre rapport maintenant avec
le gouvernement puisque on a vu que sur
le texte sur les régions le gouvernement
n'a pas tellement entendu la position du
gouvernement à ce que vous expay large
sur ce texte du sénat pardon sur ce
texte sur les compétences et bien
trouver une position commune avec le
gouvernement et avec l'assemblée
nationale qu'il ya une cohérence parce
qu'on a dit au gouvernement écouter les
régions très bien elles vont être grande
mais soit vous faites des régions grosse
obèses c'est à dire que vous allez les
charger avec des compétences du
quotidien né il ya un paradoxe si vous
voulez élargir le périmètre
il faut relever l'horizon donc tout ce
qui est de la gestion pure et dure par
exemple les transports scolaires les
limites posées les routes
départementales garanties de la part du
gouvernement
je pense que en exprimant cette
cohérence l'association des savates je
pense que oui je pense qu'une grande
partie de notre vision par exemple sur
la clarification des compétences sur
l'app
ximité ensuite de la décentralisation en
confiant aux régions un certain nombre
de responsabilités supplémentaires en
matière d'emploi en n'écartant pas les
métropoles
parce que quand même le fait
métropolitain il est important on a des
grandes métropoles qui sont créées on
peut pas les écarter de la politique
économique
donc je crois que au contraire parce que
nous on est très branché sur les
réalités du terrain on exprimait une
vraie vision d'une france moderne et non
pas d'une france napoléonienne
quand le gouvernement voudrait que
toutes les intercommunalités partout en
france
en montagne en plein en milieu urbain ou
périurbain face au moins vingt mille
habitants mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que la loi du nombre
la loi du nom c'est la négation de la
dimension humaine c'est les bassins de
vie qui sont importants mais faut la
diversité et la france c'est la
diversité
il ya plein de territoires différents
c'est la ruralité c'est la paire
urbanité cesser le fait m à paulhan
entendre au sénat lors de la discussion
vous critiquez beaucoup la position du
gouvernement sur les territoires mais
non pas du tout mais fine et françois
hollande avait pas quand même en train
de réussir sa réforme territoriale non
tout le monde peut-il bien tenu que
françois hollande a pensé que eu un
exercice de coloriage de la carte c'est
à dire qu'il suffisait de réduire à 13
les régions un exercice qu'il a fait
avec ses grands parents avec dayan avec
les grands barons il l'a fait avec les
grands barons ces grands féodaux écouter
non mais ma position ne changerait pas
il a fait ce redécoupage seul à peu près
dans son bureau et sans pour autant
avoir de la cohérence sur le contenu
c'est la distribution des cartes et
responsabilités des compétences donc
c'est une réforme qui n'est pas achevée
nous ont essayé d'y mettre de l'ordre
j'espère que le gouvernement va enfin le
comprendre c'est son intérêt pourquoi
parce que c'est l'intérêt de la france
vraiment vraiment ok donc ça c'était
pour les territoires vrai qu'on parle
maintenant un petit peu de l'image du
sénat le sénat qui a basculé à droite il
ya maintenant quatre mois de ça on n'a
pas l'impression que les choses mais
beaucoup bougé pour l'instant
demain soir il ya encore une émission à
charge sur france télévisions qu'est ce
que le sénat droite et notamment la
présidence de gérard larcher a fait pour
faire bouger un petit peu les lignes par
son image très dégradée
moi j'ai mal vécu la période traisnel
d'autres que moi d'ailleurs qui ne sont
pas non plus de la même partie on lan
pas bien vécu moi je pense que ce qui a
changé
d'abord c'est la présidence ça n'est pas
absolument ça n'est pas la cacophonie
qu'on a connus aujourd'hui
pouvez vous me dire un seul texte déjà
je parle de l'image
oui mais oui mais l'image du sénat s'est
d'ailleurs c'est d'abord d'avoir
politiquement non pas une cacophonie
mais une cohérence et nous avons une
vraie cohérente sur des positions fortes
entre l'ump nos partenaires de l'ue des
issas je crois que c'est reconnu le
gouvernement même nous dit que c'est
plus facile de travailler même si on
s'oppose avec la série qui a eu les deux
auri gérard larcher est exactement
exactement deuxième chose est la
cohérence il ya une ligne 1 k deuxième
chose gérard larcher dès qu'il est
arrivé il nous indiquait je vais faire
deux groupes de travail l'un pour
rénover comment dirais-je et lutter
contre l'absentéisme rénové donc les
pratiques du sénat on est en train d'y
travailler dans quelques semaines y aura
des conclusions on va jean boulet
beaucoup de choses et sur un certain
nombre d'aspects qui ont trait au budget
qui ont trait aux moyens des sénateurs
on va aussi bouger à certain nombre de
choses simplement
moi j'en ai absolument marc bachini du
sénat bascule du sénat ba chine j'en ai
absolument marre parce que bien sûr on
peut être bien sûr les sénateurs peuvent
pas le train quand on va de province moi
je suis un provincial à paris mais alors
ça voudrait dire que les parisiens
pourrait se rendre gratuitement au sénat
parce qu'ils habitent paris et nous les
provinciaux ceux qui habitent loin on
voudra la profession que la profession
mais la cité sa réserve parlementaire
alors la réserve parlementaire
la machine allemande en position j'ai
fait les propositions et je les applique
m jégo sur la première réforme que j'ai
proposé à mon groupe et qui est passé
c'est de lier une partie de la réserve
parlementaire à la présence des
sénateurs plus les sénateurs seront
présents plus ils pourront donner aux
communes et notamment plus petites
communes qui manquent de moyens pour
leur investissement
la réserve qui est celle du sénat mais
les ministres dans les ministères vous
avez ainsi me sers l'intérieur un
système des systèmes et nous je pense
qu'on a clarifié on est dans la
transparence et j'ai voulu une équité en
plus entre tous les sénateurs
de mon groupe ce qui sera indexé ce sera
seulement le monde tombe d'accord par
rapport à l'assiduité à la présence
est-ce qu'il fallait plus loin dans la
transparence de la vie publique françois
hollande a fait des propositions la
semaine dernière est-ce que vous allez
suivre le gouvernement le chef de l'état
sur ses positions sont bonnes mais je
pense que son monde
moi je pense que cadet scénaristique
ayral qui parle d'inquisition qu'est ce
que ça va trop loin parce que il parce
que je veux dire qu'on nous on un effort
de transparence à faire mais on est
excédés par une sorte de suspicion
évidemment vous trouvez dans et il ya
des débordements dans chaque comment
dirais-je dans chaque catégorie
professionnelle mais je pense qu'en tout
cas et c'est ce que je veux c'est ce que
je souhaite pour le bon groupe
d'ailleurs il ya une transparence des
comptes comme pour les autres groupes je
pense ça sera la conclusion du groupe de
travail avec une certification ça déjà
été d'ailleurs une conclusion de la
présidente précédentes la présidence et
je pense que sur un certain nombre
d'actions qui pourront permettre une
meilleure transparence meilleure
clarification
nous serons au rendez vous je vous la
sur les choses bougent les choses
bougent donc vous avez déposé après
laffaire thévenot une proposition de loi
sur l'inéligibilité des élus condamnés à
ce qu'elle va être inscrite à l'ordre du
jour non mais j'attends que le président
de république moi j'avais indiqué à
l'époque puisqu'il y avait des grandes
déclarations à gauche personne ne
bougeait et j'avais indiqué que je
déposais cette proposition de loi que
j'avais préparé d'ailleurs pendant
pendant l'été pour forcer les uns et les
autres à se positionner
alors désormais il ya un certain nombre
de propositions qui sont sur la table il
ya la proposition de loi il ya d'autres
projets et je pense que d'ailleurs dans
ce que l'on met la zonda république on
l'a vu phong
moi je la défends mais j'avais j'avais
aussi indiqué réponse aux mails
elle n'est pas en sommeil simplement
j'avais indiquent ils j'avais indiqué
que c'était une proposition que il n'y
avait pas de copyright et pouvait être
réutilisés qui pouvait y avoir d'autres
meilleur système
si par exemple il ya ce système du jour
et oblige par exemple un candidat à
avoir un quitus de la négociation
fiscale pour qu' il n'y ait pas de
problèmes lorsqu'ils se présentent les
élections ça sera très bien donc il faut
faire maintenant l'exécutif ils nous
l'ont indiqué il ya quelques jours
c'était le président république lors de
ses voeux va faire des propositions et
si les propositions sont bonnes
vous les soutiendrons bien sûr vous êtes
candidat aux élections régionales bruno
retailleau donc les élections de
décembre prochain décembre 2015 est ce
que ça veut dire que vous allez choisir
entre votre mandat de sénateur ou deux
et où deux présidents de régions non
j'ai choisi de renoncer au départemental
oui elle a choisi renonçant
départementales qui sont dans à la fin
du mois de mars
mais j'ai toujours considéré toujours
considéré qu' en france il ne fallait
pas avoir d' élus hors sol moi je suis
un élu enracinée et je pense que si
demain vous n'avez que des parlements
2,7
si vous ne le verrez bien neuf on verra
bien été votée sur la limite à autres
lois dans notre loi peuvent être voté
aussi je pense que si demain vous voulez
avoir des appareils je pensais que l'ump
si elle arrive au pouvoir en 2012 elle
doit revenir absolument sur la ligne
mais en tout cas ce que je pensais que
demain si vous voulez remplir les
hémicycles de l'assemblée nationale ou
du sénat de gens qui sont complètement
déconnectés des réalités du terrain des
gens qui seront des apparatchiks vous
faites ça et vous verrez je ne suis pas
sûr politique conseiller régional
forcément les rives et oui ça serait
quand même un cumul finalement ça serait
quand même le cumul moi je pense que la
france allait joindre de cela et en plus
tant que la france sera la france et que
les décisions seront prises à paris eh
bien il faut que pour nos régions pour
nos départements on puisse avoir une
influence sur la vie parisienne
tout simplement parce que la france est
encore trop parisienne est trop jacobine
ça veut dire qu'il faut encore plus
décentralisée c'est ce que j'ai indiqué
c'est ce que nous avons fait les
critiques emmanuel macron pour sa loi
tout allait à ce que vous vous
critiquent également la formule de
l'utiliser il avait dit qu'il fallait
qu'il y ait plus de jeunes français qui
est envie de devenir milliardaire
ouais je veux pas polémiquer vous savez
ce sont de petites phrases c'est un
effet le rêve de langage
marisol touraine se distinguent il dit
non c'est pas ça qu'on peut proposer aux
jeunes c'est en quelques occasions
nationale en a parlé au début d'émission
je demande à ce que je demandais même
elle macro comme ce que je demande à
manuel valls et françois hollande c'est
de prendre les bonnes réformes les
bonnes dispositions pour un témoin de
laurence est au chômage
c'est pas le problème que les français
deviennent milliardaire je suis désolé
c'est que des millions de familles
françaises qui souffrent du chômage
aujourd'hui il ya
plus de cinq millions de français qui
souffrent du chômage total ou partiel
bien je pense que c'est à eux d'abord
qu'il faut penser c'est là le problème
c'est recréer des milliardaires
il y aura toujours des milliardaires
c'est pas le problème le souci c'est de
donner du travail aux français je
réponds d'aller vers ce y compris nos
retailleau merci d'arrêter anna merci à
tous françois rey a très vite
là